With so many big, world-shaking things happening
in every episode of Game of Thrones, it can
be easy to overlook some of the smaller moments.
Here's a spoiler-filled look at some things
only real fans noticed in the final season
of Game of Thrones.
Since the beginning of the show, Daenerys
has adopted different traditions and styles
from the various tribes and groups she's led
and joined, and perhaps the most influential
group in her young life is the Dothraki, thanks
to the fact that she became a queen of the
warrior tribe upon her marriage to Khal Drogo.
The Dothraki place an enormous importance
upon the length and style of their hair, especially
for the men: the more braids a man sports,
the more victories he's won in battle, and
a Dothraki warrior only cuts his hair if he
loses a fight, so the longer the mane, the
more formidable the warrior.
"When Dothraki are defeated in combat, they
cut off their braid so the whole world can
see their shame.
Khal Drogo has never been defeated."
As a result, Daenerys has sported a lengthy
mane featuring a fierce tangle of braids for
several seasons.
But the fifth episode of the eighth season
finds her at a disadvantage, having lost two
of her most trusted advisors, Jorah and Missandei
. When Tyrion checks on her at Dragonstone,
her braids are mussed, undone, and ragged,
letting the audience know that the Dragon
Queen is losing her grip, and will end up
risking everything to get back on top.
When Daenerys was married to the warrior lord
Khal Drogo in Thrones' first season, she didn't
anticipate having to fight all of her own
battles, mostly because Drogo, a prideful
and formidable fighter, was all too happy
to wage war on her behalf.
When Daenerys told him she was pregnant with
his son, who was prophesied to be a Messiah-like
figure known as the "Stallion Who Would Mount
the World," Drogo made a passionate promise
to take the Iron Throne on Daenerys' behalf.
That sort of violent destruction is exactly
what Daenerys and her Dothraki hordes unleashed
on King's Landing in the fifth episode of
the final season.
It seemed out of character, until you remember
that Daenerys made a similar pact with the
Dothraki back in season six.
Looks like she has more than kept both of
those promises.
After losing her husband, Daenerys made several
attempts to find armies and benefactors to
back her in the war to come, and during Thrones'
second season, she ran afoul of the warlocks
of Qarth, who stole her dragons and lured
her into the terrifying and mystical House
of the Undying to get them back.
Naturally, Daenerys charged into the temple
to track down her "children" and experienced
a number of visions along the way, seeing
everything from her late husband Drogo and
their lost child to a battered and seemingly
destroyed Iron Throne.
Standing in an empty and ravaged Throne Room,
it seems as if Daenerys is surrounded by snow,
but thanks to the aftermath of King's Landing
in the wake of her ruthless and murderous
siege, it's clear that her vision has come
true, and it's not snow, but ashes.
Many viewers always believed that the snow
was a sign of the Night King, but perhaps,
at this point, Daenerys' reign of fire and
blood is even more dangerous and destructive
than the Night King himself, and before long,
audiences will likely see Daenerys standing
in the real, ransacked version of the Throne
Room, ready and determined to take whatever
is left of the Iron Throne itself.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Game of
Thrones are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.